praise saul another season of raised by
wolves has come and gone and it's only
fitting that the very last line of the
season is
in this video we'll be going over the
final episode of the season theories for
season three and a whole lot more i've
also left timestamps for all the topics
i'll be covering so feel free to skip
ahead to what interests you the most
that being said it's been an amazing
journey so far and i hope you'll like
subscribe and leave a comment it's the
best way you can support the channel if
you've been enjoying these videos vril's
writing this is very much a loose end
going into season three and it would be
a huge letdown of what paul said about
the writing is true that it's just quote
dopey earth stuff vril deemed this
information to be important saying it's
consisted of the real vril's diary
entries we know that the real vril had a
tumultuous relationship with her mother
and last episode we got some pretty
interesting information that her mother
decima worked for one of the companies
responsible for the destruction of
earth's atmosphere when the river land
her mother was profiting off weapons
that were destroying the earth's
atmosphere my best guess so far is that
these writings contain some sort of code
to create and or reprogram something
into a weapon remember that campion
sturgis was the only person to
successfully reprogram a necromancer i
can't help but think there's a
connection between vril who may have
been working with the atheist because
she hated her mithraic mother so much
and campion that might also explain
kepler champion's special relationship
with vril
i loved it so what if this writing
contains something that could reprogram
a necromancer and who knows they may
even bring vril back not entirely sure
how but this line for mother leaves the
possibility open machines do not die
champion
we break down the death of the serpent
well rest in peace baby snake it's been
a rough season for you the finale
unfortunately leaves us with more
questions than answers when it comes to
the snake but there are some interesting
observations to be made that call into
question everything we know about it
first is the snake's pursuit of campion
now it may just be me but i really think
that if the snake wanted to kill
champion here it easily could have like
we see it clearly hesitating before
firing off these necromancer screams
into the ocean i think it's actually
warning campion here do not go in the
water this makes more sense when we
later hear champions say this the
water's warmer than the air
wish we could go in in fact i don't
think the serpent is bad at all the
first thing it did when escaping
captivity was to destroy the very object
that it was allowing the entity to
circumvent the emf field it's a tragic
death for the serpent when it's killed
by its own mother even wanting to
connect to her for milk not knowing she
had her port sealed a few episodes prior
the lullaby mother uses to lure the
serpent into space is the same song she
sang to campion when he was born
[Music]
mother leads the serpent above the
planet's atmosphere and her scream
causing the serpent to come crashing
back to the ground seems to disrupt the
tropical zone's electromagnetic field
which you can see here with these
hexagonal markings we'll see these same
hexagons when grandmother repairs the
hibernation pods i wonder if there's a
connection with the electromagnetic
field destroyed this will leave all our
characters susceptible to the entity's
influence and it also seems to have
changed the weather there's even the
talk of potentially moving should it get
too cold with the serpent destroyed
mother reaches into its eye to retrieve
this unknown object just like mother
puts in her eyes to weaponize maybe this
is the serpent's version of that why
include this moment unless this object
will come into play next season and if
things can get even weirder the
serpent's body decays and sprouts into a
tree perhaps this is the result of
having eaten sue marcus and the upside
down cross well marcus has gone on one
hell of a journey from staunch believer
back to atheist he like mother wants to
see the entity destroyed after all it
was the thing that turned sue into a
tree yes it still sounds weird when i
say that when marcus learns from paul
that the entity was using the tree as a
way to connect it from the core to the
tropical zone he knows the answers to
finding and potentially destroying it
may lie within one of those pits so he
travels back to the temple where the
bodies of vril's victims still lay dead
but unfortunately for him he's shot by
lucius lucius wants nothing more than to
kill marcus for being a false prophet
and false prophets deserve to be
punished and killed slowly this is why
he's crucified upside down while wearing
the punisher helmet for lucius believes
marcus should die in darkness the
upside-down crucifixion imagery is
something that's been hinted at before
take a look at this painting caleb and
mary find in season one the origins of
the upside down cross are believed to
originate with the death of saint peter
one of jesus's apostle the story goes
that he did not believe himself to be
worthy to be killed in the same manner
as christ so he asked to be crucified
upside down it's actually only until
fairly recently that the upside down
cross has been associated as an
anti-christian or satanic symbol when
lucius takes off the punisher helm we
can see that marcus is still alive by
the movement around his mouth but tam
does he not look good a little time does
pass after so it's possible that he did
die and if so marcus's resurrection
would mimic that of christ lucius says
that he is now the prophet and that he
will be king proving that the entity has
now taken a hold of him now there's two
ways to interpret this wild ending the
first and not as exciting is that this
never happened at all lucius is
hallucinating as a result of the
entity's hold over him but if what
lucius sees is real it raises far more
questions how did this happen how did
nailing himself to this tree give him
the ability to levitate basically in the
same manner that necromancers do only
upside down we know that these trees dig
deep into the ground to establish a
connection to the core it's a way of
getting energy maybe that's what has
given marcus these powers this also begs
the question if marcus will have some
sort of connection with sue if sue
became a part of the planet is she still
there in some form or another on to
tempus baby last episode we saw how
hunter killed the sea creature to get
tempus baby back well it looks as though
the sea creature's milk has altered the
baby's genetic makeup giving it webbed
fingers and i can't help but think the
sea creature milk is somehow linked to
the devolution process that grandmother
so desperately wants after all she says
the marine fungus that the sea creatures
eat can be used as nutrition should the
fruit die from the cold and this marine
fungus will likely facilitate in this
devolution process a process which has
already started to affect people like
campion grandmother also makes it clear
that they should not eat the sea
creatures you should not eat the
creatures
it causes problems if these creatures
are our ancestors it would be tantamount
to cannibalism but why is grandmother
wanting to devolve humanity she was
programmed to ensure the everlasting
life of it but sees the only way to
ensure this is by devolving them to such
an extent they become ignorant
essentially the sheep to her shepherd
ignorance is bliss
not quite bliss
but
key to survival the title of this
episode is happiness which relates to
grandmother's belief that the
everlasting life of humanity hinges on
their happiness over knowledge that it
is better to be happy and ignorant than
knowledgeable and bitter with the truth
on the official grandmother poster
released by hbo you'll see the tagline
sacrifice for survival which hearkens
back to the conversation grandmother had
with mother about how the ancient humans
the technocrats couldn't rationalize why
a being like the entity and snake would
want to destroy itself one might destroy
itself if it means ensuring the survival
of others and that's essentially what
grandmother is doing when grandmother
puts mother into hibernation she tells
her of this plan that she had to alter
the equation of her programming to get
her desired answer everlasting life or
humanity in order to produce the
necessary answer i had to alter the
equation she says that humans will still
be humans just a simpler
happier version of themselves her goal
is that when all the humans have
devolved to a point where they go back
into the water the entity will return to
its slumber and she promises to release
mother from hibernation the important
bit of info i get out of this is that
the core seems to only be active so long
as humans are a threat to it so maybe
the core is the planet's protective
mechanism ensuring humanity doesn't kill
it and itself similar to what it did on
earth that's why when humanity is
devolved and no longer a threat it will
go back to its slumber but its mother
here who has the counter argument yes
this may be the logical thing to do to
ensure survival but it's not the right
thing to do and that's one of the things
i love about the show the philosophical
questions it begs two parts of the
devolution process seem to revolve
around the fungus and a video game she
has produced to give to the colony my
best guess is that the video game is
some form of brainwashing which will
allow her to easily shepherd her flock
it's no surprise then that the
star-shaped game cartridge that it comes
in is six pointed just like saul's star
that will see lucius carving both seem
to be used as a symbol of control one
via electronics the other via religion
grandmother also seems to have plans
with father she even makes a move on him
to which he counters by stating his
devotion to mother remember that when
grandmother first awoke she wondered why
father wasn't wearing his veil and why
he was speaking this language she even
states that the two of them are partners
it seems as though she knew him from
before there's definitely something
grandmother is hiding from father that
we don't yet know mother the veil and
hibernation let's talk a bit about
mother herself who has put on
grandmother's veil to null herself of
emotion allowing her to kill her child
the snake this veil will eventually be
her downfall as it literally ends up
consuming her i also love the attention
to detail that creators have put into
the show as when mother is confronted by
extremely emotional moments such as
their interaction with campion her veil
starts to go apeshit almost as if it's
working overtime to null these emotions
this same veil turning red is
experienced by grandmother when she
finds out there are humans on the planet
but what i find more interesting is
where mother ends up while hibernating
remember that when the mathrack used the
hibernation pods to escape earth they
were put in a virtual sim so that they
could all be together during their long
journey this is what mother accessed in
season 1 where she was impregnated by
virtual campion in fact that's exactly
where mother is teleported to when she
arrives in the sim this virtual
monastery where she and campion made
love it looks as though season 3 will
start with mother reunited with champion
sturgis and i wonder if we'll even get
some cool flashbacks just like we saw
when mother entered the pod in season
one the tarot cards earlier in the
season we learned these cards may
contain data and father even uses this
device to play a gruesome video
depicting what happens to those who
touch the seeds we've seen many of these
cards throughout seasons 1 and 2.
there's even one depicting a human
upside down but i'm not exactly sure if
this was to foreshadow marcus these
cards seem to depict a cycle that has
happened and will happen again i wonder
if these other cards offer similar
videos which may shine a light on some
of the planet's biggest mysteries the
hologram video they watch also depicts a
scene of cloaked figures surrounding a
tree that is very reminiscent to what
mother saw at the end of season 1.
however in that scenario the figures
were surrounding an android head spewing
white liquid contained within a
dodecahedron the relics grandmother
clearly states that the humans
especially the children like vida are
not to play with any of the relics veda
magically finds one with each side
covered in eyes the tree box contained a
seed maybe this one has necromancer eyes
in it at this point it's become so
frequent characters finding random
things that i can't help but think
there's some other force wanting the
humans to collect them almost as if it's
wanting to make sure they are found
either that or it's just very lazy
writing which leads me to another theory
that there are actually two entities one
which is more powerful and controls the
voice and another that is secretly
working behind the scenes to undermine
the other's plan now this one is really
easy to miss but when they are watching
the hologram you can hear an ancient
mythic lullaby playing as part of the
recording
it's the same thing sue sings to paul
the sun has sung
the shadowy night
rita sings it as well
[Music]
and the lyrics go way back to season one
when ambrose recites it the sun is sunk
the shadowy night is raining in your
room it playing as part of this
recording confirms its origins bullenia
go and that we are likely descendants of
these ancient humans the punisher helm
is also interesting mother states relics
like this might somehow be connected to
the entity with the emf field destroyed
could these relics act as conduits
between their holders and one or two of
these entities remember that marcus
resurrected after the punisher mask was
put on his face and that this is to our
knowledge the first time it's ever been
put on someone after the emf field had
been destroyed is there a connection
bick hunter's android we get a super
short scene where nerva asks hunter
about the android he's been working on
it seemed like a very odd scene to add
especially since bick the name of this
android has played absolutely no role in
the plot at all all he's been so far is
extra vfx dollars the production had to
spend i can't help but think they're
setting this droid up for something near
the end of the episode a little girl has
fashioned a medallion in the shape of
mother and calls it god
larmia the serpent killer
lamia the god if an android can be made
a god can the reverse not also be true a
god as android what i'm trying to say
here is if the entity which was once
perceived as the god saul is in reality
an ancient machine we've just given it
the name god because we can't begin to
comprehend its power or how it works and
what about that fruit run by fruiting
one thing i hope wasn't just a red
herring was the tree fruit much of the
colony ate in episode vii as far as we
know only marcus paul and vida had some
of it but the question remains whether
it will have any sort of impact on the
characters i could see this however
being an abandoned plot point in season
3. so that's the bulk of what i wanted
to cover in this video but now i leave
it open to you what are your thoughts
and theories about raised by wolves and
what do you think we can expect in
season three thanks again for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember